foreign
requirements lifecycle management is the
knowledge area that describes the tasks
that a business analyst performs to
manage and maintain requirements right
from initiation to the final
implementation the process includes
monitoring planning analyzing managing
and communicating organizational
requirements so it's clear that managing
the lifecycle requirements can have a
deciding impact on the outcome of the
project managing requirements lifecycle
requires a business analyst to manage
and maintain requirements while
identifying relationships with designs
assessing changes and helping each
consensus on those changes welcome to
Simply love today we will discuss
requirements lifecycle management
tutorial your gateway to mastering the
art of orchestrating optimizing and
breathing life into critical heartbeat
of any project requirements that said if
these are the type of videos you'd like
to watch then hit that subscribe button
and the bell to get notified and if you
are a professional with minimum one year
of experience and a mass pairing
business analyst looking for online
training and certifications from the
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply launch
postgraduate program and business
analysis from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
for more details use the link in the
description box below also if you're a
professional with minimum one year of
experience and already a brilliant
business analyst and want to upgrade
your skills to become a successful data
with proper training and certifications
from the experts and repeated
universities then Caltech data science
boot camp should be the right choice for
you for more details use the link in the
description box below so without further
Ado let's get started we will get
started by understanding what exactly is
requirements lifecycle management and
followed by that we will go through the
different stages of requirement
lifecycle management and then we will
understand each and every stage in a bit
more detail that is by understanding
Trace requirements then maintain
requirements followed by that
prioritized requirements and next assess
requirements changes and lastly approved
requirements I hope I made myself clear
with the agenda now let's get started
with the first topic what is
requirements life cycle management the
answer for this question is the process
of monitoring planning analyzing
managing and communicating
organizational requirements is called
requirements life cycle management it's
clear that managing the life cycle of
requirements can have a deciding impact
on the outcome of the project managing
requirements lifecycle requires a
business analyst to manage and maintain
requirements while identifying
relationships with designs assessing
changes and helping reach consensus on
those changes now let's proceed with the
stages of requirements life cycle
management
so requirements lifecycle management has
five different stages first you will get
to trace the requirements then you
maintain the requirements proceeding
ahead you have the prioritization of
requirements next you have assessing of
requirements and the changes required
and lastly approve the changes now let's
understand each one of them in detail
firstly Trace requirements
tracing requirements involves analysis
and maintaining relationships between
requirements designs and solutions which
should provide the basis for impact
analysis allocation and coverage the
life cycle of every requirement needs to
be identified and recorded in a way that
ensures backward and forward
stressability through traceability the
business analyst can ensure that the
solution is aligned to the requirement
and manage the scope timeline risks and
potential costs it's also helpful for
discovering requirement inconsistencies
and flaws and provide a better
understanding of the change tracing
enables the analysts to assess at any
given moment if certain requirements
have been addressed or not the elements
of requirements tracing are level of
formality relationships traceability
repository the main guidelines and tools
used for tracing the requirements are
domain knowledge information management
approach legal or regulatory information
and requirements management tools or
repositories the techniques that the
business analyst will most likely use
are business rules analysis functional
decomposition process modeling and scope
modeling for this let's proceed to the
next stage which is about maintaining
requirements maintaining requirements is
necessary for keeping the requirements
and Designs accurate and current
throughout the cycle it also enables
their reuse if needed maintenance of
requirements is crucial for preserving
their validity through a process
especially since it represents a certain
organizational need to maximize the
benefits from maintaining environments
the business analyst must make sure that
the requirements are consistently
represented approved and reviewed using
standard procedures and easy to access
to understand now the main elements of
requirements maintenance are maintaining
requirements maintaining attributes
reusing requirements now while
maintaining requirements the business
analysts commonly use information
management approach as a useful
guideline or tool besides this there are
several helpful business analysts
techniques business rule analysis data
flow diagrams data modeling document
analysis functional decomposition
process modeling use cases and scenarios
and user stories now proceeding ahead we
have prioritized requirements
prioritizing requirements or ranking
them in order of importance helps
business analysts access the value risk
and urgency related to the certain
requirement and Designs this ensures
that the most important requirements and
Designs are always at the top of the
queue for analysis the relevance of the
requirements to their stakeholders plays
the most important part of the ranking
and according to this the requirement
can be prioritized to a greater or
lesser extent the task of prioritizing
requirements has three key elements
which are basis of prioritization
challenges of prioritization and
Continuum prioritization there are also
some useful business analysis techniques
for this process such as backlog
management business cases decision
analysis estimation Finance financial
analysis interviews item tracking
prioritization risk analysis and
management workshops Etc now proceeding
further we will understand the next
stage that is SS requirements when
assessing requirements change the
business analysts evaluate every
existing and potential new stakeholder
requirement and design so they can make
an informed decision whenever an action
on those requirements is required every
change to the requirements and Designs
has its implications and analysts assess
those changes to estimate the impact of
those changes on the project this task
need to be performed every time a new
need arises or the possible solution is
proposed now there are three main
elements of task of assessing
requirements changes are assessment
formality impact analysis impact
resolution also there are some key
business techniques used for this
particular step which are business cases
business rules analysis decision
analysis requirement analysis estimation
financial analysis interface analysis
interviews item tracking risk analysis
and management and lastly workshops
proceeding further the last stage which
is approved requirements during the
approving of the requirements the
business analysts work closely with the
stakeholders with the role in the
garnish process to approve and agree on
certain requirements and Designs
reaching the agreement and obtaining
approval is crucial for the continuation
of the business analysis process the key
elements of the requirements approval
tasks Landing stakeholders rules
conflict and issue management gaining
consensus and lastly tracking and
communicating the approval some business
analysis techniques that will be most
likely used in this particular segment
are acceptance and evaluation criteria
decision analysis item tracking reviews
and workshops and with that we have
reached to the Love Stage of requirement
man title but before we end the session
let's hear from our Learners about their
personal experience and their success
stories after getting graduated from the
business Analytics program offered by
simply loan
I'm Cortana
live in
Enron working as a business analyst at
levature
this is my second job since I completed
the postgraduate program in business
analytics I simply learned with Purdue
University my experience with simple
learning was great the live classes were
my favorite because they were very
interactive and I could connect with
instructors have many small gaps and
short Employments in my career
I even have a huge two-year career Gap
due to some health issues however I
think the dark times are now behind me
it doesn't matter how challenging the
path may be keep upscaling and one day
you will achieve successful feeling
inspired already consider checking the
business analysis postgraduate program
offered by simply learn from Purdue
University in collaboration with IBM for
more details check out the link in the
description box below and with that we
have come to an end of the session on
requirements management life cycle if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources used in the
session then please do let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of X Plus we'll be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you for watching
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign